so und weil die laune gerade so gut ist
reden wir doch mal über saudi arabien
muss sein
reden wir über saudi-arabien und den
mordfall peggy der regimekritische
journalist betritt das saudische
konsulat in istanbul und kommt nicht
mehr raus
jedenfalls nicht lebend und wie
unglaublich dilettantisch saudi arabien
versucht diesen brutalen auftragsmord zu
vertuschen
kurz bevor türkische ermittler das
konsulat betreten dürfen erscheint wie
zufällig eine putzkolonne und macht den
tatort besenrein schiffe sind upfinger
restmüll oder gelbe tonne
danach kam und das ist leider kein witz
ernsthaft noch die maler aber sobald die
farbe trocken war haben die saudis den
türken wirklich alles gezeigt und sich
dabei auch überhaupt nicht verdächtig
benommen
besonders bizarr um zu zeigen dass ich
kein shopping nicht dem konsulat
auffällt öffnet der diplomat
verschiedene schränke
doch der verdacht bleibt
sie sehen der kommissar shi qi ist nicht
hier aber mal was anderes wollen teppich
kaufen
er ist frisch gereinigt alles sehr
rätselhaft meine damen und herren und
ein klarer fall für sherlock olli fassen
wir also noch mal kurz zusammen was wir
wissen
die fakten das killerkommando landet um
drei uhr morgens in istanbul und zwar
mit dem privatjet des saudischen
kronprinzen mohammed bin salman kurz mbs
an bord ein 15-köpfiges hit team
bestehend aus geheimdienst männern und
leibwächtern aus dem direkten umfeld von
richtig mohammed bin salman diese
lustige reisegruppe sollte cascioli im
konsulat angeblich nur verhören
aber da bleiben fragen sie hatten zum
beispiel keinen ersatz dabei sondern
einen gerichtsmediziner
warum wohl und sie hatten eine
knochensäge dabei wozu war die wo ja gut
so eine knochensäge kann man für alles
mögliche gebrauchen wer weiß vielleicht
für eine schöne traditionelle arabische
laubsägearbeit das kann doch sein
übrigens hat der chef des teams am tag
des mordes viermal den büroleiter von
genau mohammed bin salman angerufen aus
istanbul und das opfer cascioli hat in
seinem blog immer wieder einen
kronprinzen kritisiert namens und das
habe ich echt nicht kommen sehen
mohammed bin salman
das alles lässt für mich als erfahrener
ermittler nur einen schluss zu der
mörder war der gärtner mit der rohrzange
im billardzimmer meine damen und herren
[Musik]
rainer lux
fall gelöst die führer der freien welt
sind entsetzt über den mord einer
allerdings hat er probleme mit der
ausführung
die hinrichtung war dilettantisch und
die vertuschung wenn man es so nennen
will war ebenfalls schlecht insgesamt
ein totales fiasko erster ich hätte so
viel besser gemacht natürlich als dieser
komische dilettanten prinzler aus saudi
arabien das kann doch alles nicht mehr
wahr wenn wirklich ja inzwischen spricht
auch die saudische staatsanwaltschaft
von einer vorsätzlichen tötung sagt loos
war es doch kein selbstmord und der
prinz setzt sich diese woche in
staatsfernsehen und sagt stumpf fürchten
zuerst einmal dieses verbrechen ist
wirklich schmerzhaft für alle saudis und
ich glaube es ist schmerzhaft für alle
menschen auf der erde hear the world
ich möchte behaupten besonders
schmerzhaft war schon für pathologie
aber das ist nur meine theorie mbs der
eigentliche herrscher einer blutigen
diktatur man sagt in deutschland immer
autokratie dass eine diktatur der duldet
keine kritik und keinen widerspruch und
da kommt mit allem durch natürlich wäre
es in der theorie schön wenn die
weltgemeinschaft saudi arabien mal einen
tritt in die weichteile verpasst aber
das wird nicht passieren
in dieser woche bei seiner großen
investorenkonferenz in riad wurde mbs
mit applaus begrüßt sein land hat er in
nur zwei tagen geschäfte im wert von
über 50 milliarden dollar abgeschlossen
in dieser woche was sagt man dazu
herzlich willkommen zur kürzesten
schoder welt geld die moral sehr
bewegend geld richtig an
das war die kürzeste gegen schon
was für eine blöde show wirklich es ist
ja so niemand verhängt ernsthafte
sanktionen gegen saudi arabien niemand
und auch die deutschen waffenlieferungen
sind ja nur eingefroren ist ganz wichtig
sobald sich die aufregung weg geht das
alles wieder sein gang
ich wette dass mit ihnen unser
außenminister heiko maas ist noch
letzten september vor ein paar wochen
vor den saudis zu kreuze gekrochen und
hat sich für die ganz vorsichtige kritik
seines vorgängers gabriel quasi
entschuldigt wir gucken sie mal als mass
saudi arabien ohne rot zu werden als
garant für den frieden bezeichnet da
muss sogar wenn sie genau gucken der
saudische außenminister gegen seinen
grinsen ankämpfen relations herr smith
understanding das geschirrtuch hätte
sich vor lachen fast in den kaffee
angemacht
wirklich frieden und stabilität und für
alle kinder die sich jetzt fragen was
ist das denn für ein komisches
königshaus da in saudi arabien
das erklärt euch jetzt unser
orientalische märchenonkel serdar
somuncu ihr müsstet längst im bett sein
deswegen gibt es jetzt mal eine gute
nacht geschichte vorgelesen von einem
als araber verkleideten türken aber für
die rassistische heute schon redaktion
sehen wir ja eh alle gleich aus
die geschichte und saudi arabien im
reichsten land der welt
es war einmal ein königreich das ist
saudi arabien weil die zahlreichen
staatsreligion ist der wahabismus eine
besonders strenge form des islam
wahabismus heißt jeder der was anderes
glaubt oder den islam auch nur minimal
anders auslegten bringen wir um leute
das ist keine kindergeschichte das ist
ja hier der mann nachdem das land
benannt ist heißt eben sound er war
einer der grausamsten herrscher des
letzten jahrhunderts ebenso prallte gern
damit 18 verfeindeten stammesfürsten
höchstpersönlich den kopf abgehackt zu
haben weil sie sag mal seid ihr
bescheuert das kann ich doch nicht
vorlesen die schlagen kriegen ja
albträume saudi arabien hat keine
gewählte regierung sämtliche gesetze
müssten sich an der scharia orientieren
und da gibt es zb öffentliches
auspeitschen amputationen rain man
seit drei jahren führt seit jahren einen
unerklärten krieg gegeben wird mit den
zwischen über 10.000 toten und über zwei
millionen vertriebenen auch nicht der
mit abstand berühmteste sohn des landes
heißt osama bin laden er hat am 11
september kein bock mehr ich gehe nach
hause
[Musik]